selah chavala is on his way to work the
32 year old lives in langa South
Africa's oldest Township he's a
well-respected member of the community
what of it in his pants though he chose
a different path after metric I had
nothing to do no aspirations to go to
university so i started doing business
or parties to cash and trendy choice and
if at the time that i was 18 already own
two cars and renting an apartment out of
out of the township in the city wedding
expensive designer clothes living a very
high life but then reality kicked in age
19 hotel estate and went to prison for
11 years in prison cielo started
thinking about his future he can recall
the very moment that made him change his
life when I joined the group of Hope
Project which is a nonprofit founded by
a group of prisoners who wanted to do
something fantastic with their lives
through one of the group's programs
Selah cared for orphans from a nearby
Township in addition to that he decided
to offer English and math classes to
fellow inmates without formal training
but with lots of commitment today two
years after his release from prison the
ex robber is on a mission under the roof
of the nonprofit brothers for all Selah
offers programming classes to the
township youth a source of income and a
passion project today's subject the
coding language JavaScript we create
what we call a variable sila taught
himself coding via an online course now
he teaches six days a week on this
Friday he wants to provide the 20
learners with crucial job skills
twenty-five-year-old zoeken goma is one
of them he spent the past five years in
prison for aggravated robbery
and I went to assessments test i went to
interviews they saw that I was good but
the problem was that I had a criminal
record so they couldn't take this so now
it opens doors for people like me to
actually have hope that someday I will
also do something like this for xoco his
teacher is a role model and with high
numbers of unemployment and crime and
South African townships zeal is coding
courses fulfill a crucial task to end
the cycle of poverty and crime and the
only way now to do that is to teach
these aspirational skills that will
enable these guys to get into high pay
jobs there are already signs of success
nine of seedless students have found
apprenticeships in local companies
you